she's out of the hospital right now she  is at home she'll discover she is  recovering but this is tackled you can  see it in her face my hopes are you know  my wife wants to go on she squeezes my  hand she kisses she's stringing water  she has ice cream  she wants to move on people who don't  want to move on they give up they  totally give up she wants to move on  she's fighting right now and she wants  to move on she wants to live she wants  to go on she loves everything you see  she is a non-metal  she chooses this pet worm in 1973 1973  she moved in the house she said this is  my bedroom and right now in 2016 she's  in the same battle and she's gonna stay  in that bedroom  you